[Music]
andy is 22 years old
works as a personal trainer in shanghai
and is transgender
once a month or so he gets a delivery
from thailand
and it brings a risk
[Music]
these are male hormone drugs which do
not have approval in china
[Music]
for many trans people buying medicine in
the grey market makes more sense than
through the limited official channels
buying drugs unofficially can be
dangerous with unscrupulous
[Music]
trans people administering their own
medication have experienced kidney
problems
and even paralysis as a result
they take those risks because in china
they exist in the margins
being transgender is officially classed
as a mental illness
there are three important bits of
context to all of this and the first
is the government side the laws and the
regulations in 2017
china passed a law saying that if you
have gender affirming surgery
you can change your identity on national
documents identity cards things like
that which is important
for many trans people but it doesn't
make it easy first you have to get that
diagnosis of being transgender which is
still officially
a mental illness that diagnosis itself
takes a year
and before that point you have to have
lived five years in your gender
then you still need to get your parents
consent whether you're 18 years old
whether you're 50 years old
you still need to get your parents to
sign off on that so all of that makes it
really difficult to enter the system
on the other hand that doesn't stop some
people from going through that official
process
in beijing mr c is going through the
official channels
um mr c is one of the most visible trans
men in china
after winning a court case against
workplace discrimination this summer
but he's had to fight his whole life
the second part of this is not what the
government does but it's about chinese
society's attitudes in general towards
trans people
now there's no uniformity here china has
a long tradition in its history and it's
myth
of gender diversity and in modern times
there's jin singh she is a famous
celebrity
who used to be a soldier in the people's
liberation army before she had sexual
surgery in the 90s
and a lot of people know her story but
there is a flip side
too that jin shing doesn't talk about
trans rights she doesn't try to speak
for the trans community
and throughout society at large in
eastern nature it can be
very conservative gender fluidity is
still viewed with a deep suspicion in
many places
mr c believes the only way for trans
people to be treated better
to avoid the risks many of them
currently run in the shadows
is to be more visible
foreign the last bit of context
is civil society things like ngos which
can often move
issues forward there did used to be a
lot of these for lgbt issues in china
especially in the 90s
and 2000s but since 2012 there has been
a crackdown on them not
specifically on lgbt issues but on ngos
generally china has a deep suspicion
of citizens organizing themselves and
there's less space generally
for those sort of issues to get a
hearing shanghai pride had been running
for a decade but this summer it was
closed without any reason given so a lot
of people
in the community feel like they are
being targeted they're being
sent a message that these topics are not
up for discussion in the public sphere
so without those avenues it's really
relying on individuals speaking up
speaking to the media to try and make a
difference to try and change attitudes
andy too wants his existence and his
community
to be better seen um
for now that future is something to look
to not
to live